beli eva templa avendo mai est dove
cazzo sto andando addio mi sa che ho
perso leggermente rivista la piattaforma
però vabbè vado a casa sto punto dai più
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti adesso
video sono fa vj ed era da troppo tempo
che non diciamo sta cazzo di frase è uno
che sa anche a me dopo un po mi prendeva
c'è la nostalgia per diventare
registrare quindi sembra buona presa per
il culo perché tipo ci metto 6 ora
editare un video però giuro che mi
mancava e non serve una sega sulla
faccia tosta minchia disastro che tanto
avete già letto dal titolo tutti non c'è
non c'è bisogno è arrivato allo iusm
street 20 ragazzi per chi non conoscesse
sta roba io ve lo spiego ratti con la
vela prima in te sarebbe un casco per la
realtà virtuale proprio detto così
elevate chiesto per niente tutti di
prendere questa cosa però ci ha messo
tipo sei mei ordinato sei mesi fa
arrivate ragazzi questo sarebbe il
secondo prototipo che è quello nuovo e
mi è arrivato per grazia di dio non so
neanche come vorrei ossia parte il
casinò allora io l'ho provato soltanto
per vedere come se funzionava diciamo
persona poteva incazzarmi cazzo non ho
giocato per inventa niente perché volevo
provarlo per la prima volta con voi in
diretta quindi gli ho visto che funziona
e basta cioè non so come vi di ragazzi a
sto punto direi riprovarlo perché tipo
non sto più nella pelle da mezz'ora
quindi proviamo lo è ci siamo non vi
assicuro una mazza lega pro come si fa
tremo questo sì sì se funziona più figo
è il menù più figo che abbia mai visto
da troppo che cosa ce l'hanno
luca panzavolta bene meglio di camera
mia cosa è quella pillola è una supposta
quella da giocato mentre no ok non le
teme sono ragazzi che devo fare qui il
primo in classifica si chiama si chiama
culo in seconda posizione c'è una che
vola a fingersi me ma non c'è riuscito
dunque alla prima se riesco a fare
qualcosa di indecente quanto devo
battere 45 secondi all'aci proroga
l'evoque è i pochi che cazzo cazzo
no ok allora io non mi sono allenato
molto a matrix quindi è normale rimango
così storica la triste la dorna
porca [ __ ] vista che avendo tutto fermi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ea chi abbia già puntano guarda madonna
che pro questo avventimenti secondi
minchia vai vai sono un fenomeno sta
roba
cazzo mi hanno preso e cha cha l'altra
su avviato nel quinto successo da 3 a 30
30 secondi e 2 fantastico rappresenterà
in classifica molto devo fare mica 31
per un secondo di merda entrava in
classifica fantastico non me lo so
spiegare quanto è figo ma credetemi che
è pazzesco
ok cani
[Musica]
mi sento un provare se continua tipo il
mio di madrid
che [ __ ]
adesso ho capito perché non mi ha preso
quando ho fatto il provino per matrix
state picchiate testato da sono entrato
nella hicks fantastico ragazzi prova
l'ultima volta perché non esiste che
quello abbia fatto 45 io no
allora supposta siamo soltanto io e te
adesso ok 29 30 31 9 34 ok siamo entrati
in classifica almeno quello che posso
mettere più di così mi sembra tipo
favaro l'ultima volta ragazzi se
riescono a me ma domani mi sembra di
copiare i compiti in classe di poco
poiché ecco che me lo faccio sui
movimenti
quando faccio mettendo poi non fatelo
sono vite
all'interno un proiettile da regate
questa qua questa buona questa buona
[Musica]
si arriva a mondello
si torna la donna
no
[Musica]
ecc
oh my ass credo di esserci riuscito non
ne sono sicuro
cioè non ne sono sicuro forse siamo pari
[Musica]
tua madre so ma tipo hard che cos'è sta
roba qua non vivo oggi permette grazie
un secondo e sette bellissime si sa mai
mettersi contro valigetta chiacchie
botta in faccia l'ho sentito quel
proiettile
anzi come sempre seconda [ __ ] in
tutte le foto e classifiche sono secondo
fantastico ok ragazzi ci sarà di nuovo
gara hanno aperto un altro di gioco si
chiama si chiama così iniziare un attimo
credo sia allora mi pare che sia una
piattaforma di là ecco infatti cos'è che
cazzo dove sono
dio mi mamma rimandi il suo ascensore ma
sto mettendo un piede malissimo ma ce la
fai di andare dritto non è difficile
andare dritti come si fa io devo
buttarmi giù la sto schifo
fatemi capire no no kat ok bene ragazzi
improvvisiamo senza paracadute me ne
frega un cazzo da qualche parte a terra
forse c'è il culo flash di qualcuno che
mi mia tutti se la caduta ma cazzo si fa
io devo muovere la terna bellissimo se
io devo guardare ragazzi una figata
pazzesca cazzo sbattuto contro qualsiasi
cosa si possa sbattere credo mi stanno
cadendo addosso calchi di piccione alla
velocità della luce amava ma che figata
pazzesca cosa no no merda ok ok calzoni
gozzo vivo è una figata pazza
vendo casa mia è una casa ma è grande
più grande
ho capito sì sì ce l'ho fatta ho fatto a
terrazzi perché io so i pannolini a
propulsione quindi a terra fantastico se
fracassato la tua testa e va beh sono
cose che capitano soprattutto quando
calcati da un chilometro di altezza mi
dicono mamma niente cesare grazie sono
preso le scale mameli e va che mike
myers dove cazzo sta andando purtroppo
dio mi sa che ho perso leggermente
rivista la piattaforma però la boe vado
a casa sto punto dai dove ferma
l'autobus è una roba assurda io me lo so
spiegare ragazzi dovete cos'è cazzo
sopra diventare un hamburger ghiglia
tomini con forza insomma un hamburger
credo mi hanno fatto alla griglia perché
ordo ragazzine che possono includere
video di oggi anche perché era soltanto
un test alla fine per vedere se
funzionava perché ovviamente ragazzi
videogiochi più seri anche compresi
quelli horror
purtroppo però fallì più avanti visto
che questa era soltanto un test per
vedere come funzionava anche devo dire
che mi ha impressionato tantissimo tanto
talmente alto che l'ho fatto provare
anche a mio padre minchia sensibile
anche a mia madre è giusto per sé anche
a mia nonna tutto accadesse si vedono
anche le cose ma vede una casa con le
scale si privatizza i profitti sono
girati diete e così geni e da altri
corsi dove le consente mediche bello sto
posti fa parlamento nel cannes danimarca
ecco questo è adesso quando vai in
paradiso e il paradiso e questo tutti
scegli posso andare c'è la proprietà ma
direi che tutti a non lo hanno
apprezzato quindi spero abbiate fatto
anche va comunque ricordato che questo
non era niente però due giochini
cosiddetto per provare comunque ragazzi
spero che avido vi sia piaciuto anche
sarà soltanto una prova lei e da domani
si può partire ufficialmente quindi
tenetevi pronti e se il viso è piaciuto
come al solito sotto commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook economy video
trovata una descrizione seri severi city
scapini ci vediamo al prossimo video era
ragazzi